[Musica]
molto tempo fa quando ero giovane ma non
rosso sei giovanissima non siete molto
collaborativi però è comunque un po di
tempo fa quando ero giovane va meglio e
io e il mio ragazzo decidemmo di
trasferirci sul lago di garda con la
precisione a desenzano del garda
io sono di modena è tutto nuovo
chiaramente tante le mancanze come gli
amici di sempre la mia famiglia
insomma le solite cose di quando si
cambia una città e un po di tempo dopo
camminando per la strada
trovai una cagnolina piccolina decisi di
prenderla in braccio e di portarla nella
mia nuova casa in quel periodo io e il
mio moroso prendevamo in giro quelle
coppie che si davano con i nomignoli
tipo pasticcino cicinho topolino tanto
lo so che anche qua c'è qualcuno che si
chiama cose e noi non volevamo essere da
meno quindi decidemmo di chiamarci cippa
lippa e non andrei oltre perché sta
diventando imbarazzante e quindi da lì
l'ideona come chiamiamo la nuova
arrivata cippa ecco io e mio marito non
potete segno io il mio ragazzo non
potevamo avere figli come coppia e
quindi città diventò presto per noi
proprio come una figlia
la nostra vita cambia molto tanto che
decidemmo di metterci in cerca di una
casa che avesse proprio le
caratteristiche che sposerà adatte per
lei quindi doveva avere degli spazi un
giardino di modo che lei potesse entrare
e uscire quando voleva e doveva avere le
lucertole perché lei amava rincorrere le
lucertole
vi lascio immaginare
le facce degli agenti immobiliari
era tutto perfetto avevamo finalmente
trovato la casa dei nostri sogni e dopo
dieci anni di convivenza
decidemmo anche di sposarci e mi
sembrava anche abbastanza ora chip per
noi era diventata una figlia e quindi
era la nostra gioia
lei copriva tutti quei momenti vuoti che
a volte in una coppia ci sono quindi lei
riusciva sempre modo di far uscire un
argomento o farci sorridere
insomma era proprio diventata parte
della nostra vita della nostra famiglia
eravamo una famiglia poi una sera
rientrando a casa da una cena ci
troviamo davanti alla classica scena che
ci siamo sempre sentiti raccontare dagli
amici o dei telegiornali
i ladri ci avevano scelto che ci avevano
rubato tutto
ma soprattutto ci avevano avvelenato la
nostra città e lo so si potrebbe pensare
che era solo un cane però era era la
nostra bambina e soprattutto a me
mancava tantissimo non solo quello
affetto ma non riuscivo a capacitarmi
del fatto di come un essere umano avesse
potuto fare una cosa così terribile
scusate ancora fresca per me
fu immediatamente circondata da persone
che mi dicevano cosa dovevo fare
come dovevo reagire come dovevo pensarla
e come dovevo sostituirla e poi la
fatica scena la classica frase ci sono
già passato e ti capisco invece a me
sembrava in quel momento che nessuno
sapesse di cosa io avevo veramente
bisogno quindi decisi decisi di
chiudermi in casa e di non volere più
vedere nessuno così mio marito
un bel giorno precise di tornare a casa
con un cagnolino un cagnolino tutto
bianco che chiamiamo che chiamammo oli
che chiama holly da oliver e avete
presente il classico orsetto della coca
cola eco oli era esattamente così un
cane bellissimo un cucciolo meraviglioso
che avrebbe conquistato tutti avrebbe
conquistato davvero tutti e così fu
tranne me io non ero pronta né a
sostituire la mia città e ne a guardarlo
hong kong e lui aveva capito benissimo
cosa doveva fare lui stava in disparte
mi guardava e con tutti i suoi modi
buffi riusciva anche ad ascoltare il mio
silenzio
da lì comunque questa dopo un po di
tempo questa esperienza dei ladri mi
aveva cambiato qualcosa e mi aveva in
qualche modo anche avvelenato la mia
vita e quindi decisi la notte non
dormivo perché avevo sempre questa paura
e da lì decisi di studiare di sfruttare
questo tempo in modo migliore e iniziai
a studiare tanto il processo
dell'avvelenamento nel corpo umano e
anche nel corpo degli animali e mi
accorsi che tante cose gravitavano
proprio intorno all'alimentazione
da lì cominciai a studiare dei tipi di
ricette che fossero buone e sane ma
soprattutto che fossero anche belle
perché volevo avvicinare anche i bambini
a questo tipo di alimentazione
e anche mio marito che non mangiava
nessun tipo di verdure e nel mio bambino
grande e cucinavo tutti i giorni era
proprio è diventata una vera e propria
passione per me e oli ovviamente mi
innamorai perdutamente di holly e lui
era il mio fedele compagno in cucina
più che altro aspettava che cadesse
qualcosa e da lì il passo dalla cucina
al web
fu velocissimo grazie ad un'amica social
influenze che venne a casa mia cena con
il marito vedendo tutta questa passione
che io ci mettevano il cucinare e dissi
ma perché rossana non aprì una pagina
social io cucino cosa dovevo fare
dai apriamo questa pagina social è così
a primo cucina sana cucina stanno
appunto è una pagina che parla di
alimentazione dove io tutti i giorni in
paro ricette cerco di render le belle e
la sera attraverso delle dirette le
faccio conoscere
tutto era perfetto tutto era tornato
alla normalità e io mi rasserena i anche
col mio quotidiano
avevo il mio cagnolino avevo la mia
passione quindi tutto era perfetto fino
all'anno scorso quando purtroppo la mia
vita viene di nuovo sconvolta dalla
morte della mia mamma lo so la morte
dopo la vita dopo la nascita è l'unica
certezza che abbiamo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ma io non ero pronta troppo presto e lì
mi è successa una cosa molto strana
non fui io ad allontanarmi o chiudermi
in casa ad allontanarmi dalle persone
furono le persone ad allontanarsi da me
perché non sapevano come ridare un
sorriso qualcuno che non c'era più
non sapevano quali era la frase giusta
da dire e non c'è una frase giusta da
dire effettivamente quindi guardai mio
marito e di sì andiamocene quindi carica
moholy su un aereo
io lui e holly partimmo per cinque mesi
di viaggio che fu un'esperienza
meraviglioso perché mi allontanai da
tutte quelle cose che erano il mio
quotidiano quindi le abitudini quello
che faceva ricordare il mio momento
triste no però purtroppo dovetti anche
tornare ed era tutto lì ad aspettarmi
non era cambiato nulla e soffrivo
veramente tanto e non riuscivo a
capacitarmi di come potessi fare a
risolvere questa situazione quindi quel
sant'uomo di mio marito è un'idea e
disse ti porto in un posto e andammo
fare un giorno di cucciolo terapia o non
so non si chiama così sicuramente non so
quale nome dargli però me piace questo
nome
andammo da questa signora che aveva
circa una quarantina di cuccioli e mi
misi per terra con loro iniziamo a
giocare a scopa farmeli gli davo i baci
e mi sembrava assurdo come quei 40
esserini completamente estranei
sapessero esattamente quello di cui
avevo bisogno di amore di affetto di
baci di
di una serie di cose che mi che in quel
momento riuscirono persino a farmi
ridere poi me ne andai circa dopo tre
quattro ore
anche questo è un uomo del marito si era
stufato e mi incamminai verso l'uscita e
uscendo senti una cosa strana un rumore
strano che assomigliava questo wah wah
wah wah non lo faccio benissimo però
questo era il rumore e di sicuro signora
che cos'è e mi disse guarda è un
cagnolino di cinque mesi che nessuno
vuole perché non più cucciolo molto
bruttino un po stupidi noma
esageratamente simpatico beh posso
vederlo l'ho preso in braccio e io non
so spiegarvi cosa è successo quel giorno
esattamente ma senti un brivido e come
per magia
sembrava che l'avessi sempre avuto nella
mia vita lo portammo a casa
immediatamente
e quando fui a casa guardai il
certificato di nascita ed era nato lo
stesso giorno il 4 dicembre lo stesso
giorno della mia mamma luciana
incredibile e da lì
decidemmo di chiamarlo lucio lo so
signori non siamo dei fenomeni nei nomi
proprio non ce la possiamo fare
però lucio ha proprio la faccia da lucio
ve lo posso garantire
lucio non è esattamente l'esempio di
cannes è sveglio perché lui sbatte sulle
porte in fila le zampe nella ciotola
dell'acqua non capisce un comando
neanche a morire proprio però è il mio
lucio è il nostro la nostra gioia e vi
posso assicurare che dopo un anno è
diventato anche molto bello giuro
l'amore può cambiare tante cose
[Applauso]
grazie al mio all'aiuto di oli e lucio
decisi anche di rientrare nei social
network perché in quel periodo mi ero
completamente tolta da ogni tipo di
contatto e di riaprire cucino sanno che
avevo stoppato per un periodo da lì
decisi anche di aprire una rubrica dal
nome cucino sano con la coda ad oggi il
suo nome è quelli con la coda non gli ho
dato questo nome sempre perché sono un
fenomeno nei nomi con scherzo gli ho
dato questo nome perché credo che una
coda nella propria vita voglia dire
felicità carezze può essere una serie di
cose e quindi abbiamo voluto dare questo
nome
quelli con la coda e parla di
alimentazione sana anche per i nostri
amici a quattro zampe parla di di
educazione e di consigli e con mio
immenso stupore mi trovai tutte le mie
ragazze le mie follower chiamiamole così
che mi mandarono centinaia e centinaia
di foto video di canicola cuffia con la
berretta con le scarpe con la sciarpa le
cose assurde e mi rendevo conto che in
qualche modo questi esserini tiravano
fuori la parte migliore di noi quella un
po bambina forse la parte più umana di
noi no dicevo ma per che cosa hanno
questi a farini che ho visto persone
come mio padre una persona estremamente
burbera sempre perennemente col mal di
schiena però sempre sdraiato per terra
dare baci a questo cane ho visto il mio
migliore amico di un metro e ottanta di
uomo che un armadio impazzire per questo
chihuahua che grande così e io stessa mi
sono accorta che quando cammino per la
strada spessissimo sorrido ai cani e non
saluto i padroni e mi sono detto beh è
facile no il cane miglior amico
dell'uomo giusto invece no io non penso
che il cane sia il migliore amico
dell'uomo
io penso che il cane sia una vera e
propria anima gemella
perché se ci pensiamo quando il cane a
tre mesi se fortunato conoscerà il suo
padrone e avrà sempre solo lui per tutta
la sua vita nel bene e nel male nella
buona e cattiva sorte non scodinzola era
sempre al tuo ritorno ti sveglierai ogni
mattina sempre con un bacio e lo farà
ogni sera quando vai a dormire e ti sarà
fedele sempre finché morte non ci separi
perché mi sono detta perché questa cosa
perché credo che il cane abbia il mezzo
di comunicazione più potente al mondo
ascolta e lo fa per tutta la sua vita
nonostante non conosca il nostro
linguaggio ma imparerà a capirci
benissimo a difenderci da non dagli
attacchi ma difenderci dalla negatività
duck le cose brutte che la vita
purtroppo ci riserva e quindi il mio
punto è più importante essere un umano o
essere umano perché l'essere umano nelle
mie due esperienze non aveva capito cosa
mi doveva dare o cosa cosa io avessi
bisogno di avere in quel momento mentre
i miei cagnolini nonostante fossero
estranei sapevano esattamente quello che
mi avrebbe fatto stare bene però dico
caspita ci deve essere un privilegio
nell'essere umano perché a dire il vero
sono più le volte che mi metto in dubbio
quando vedo la cattiveria la
maleducazione e l'odio il non rispetto
per l'ambiente
il non rispetto per ciò che mangiamo e
per ciò che diamo da mangiare ai nostri
figli è una guerra troppo dura perché
quotidiana e io non so come si combatte
questa guerra e quindi ho dovuto trovare
il mio modo per combatterla e ad oggi
posso dirlo urlando che il mio modo lo
trovo ogni giorno nei miei cagnolini che
sono loro
e ad oggi loro sono la parte più umana
di me è sicuramente grazie